[Music]
how did you get to mit
i sort of had a long path to getting
here but
i was a math undergrad and then i
actually was an economics phd for a
couple years before
deciding that robotics was my my true
calling and then
through a fortunate series of events
ended up working on the darpa robotics
challenge and then ended up
in in russ's lab i came to
mit after my phd at boston university
i did my phd in robotics and before i
did robotics i actually studied pigeons
and how they fly
and their dynamics of flights and so
pigeons is the way i got into robotics
by looking at the dynamics of them and
then wondering what could happen if you
could also control those systems
i finished my undergrad and my master's
back in 2011 and then i was
working in industry for two years
at johns hopkins applied physics lab
which was which was fun
um but it was more development and i
really wanted to do research i really
wanted to go back
for my phd so i worked on a few research
projects and i applied for my phd
um a few places uh got accepted to a few
got
rejected from a lot and i wound up
joining everybody here at mit for my phd
uh so i did my undergrad here
um and i really like the community and
especially i
did a europe the undergraduate research
with daniella
so i enjoyed that and i was happy to
stay on as a grad student
i won a scholarship for my research
being one of the grand challenges in
engineering
and a phd candidate at the university of
cambridge and this year i'm a charleston
best scholar at mit
i had mentioned to an undergrad
professor that i was thinking about
maybe applying to phd programs and she
said you know you should do it you
should definitely do it
you know who cares if you get it or not
you should definitely try and i think
that little push
that someone believing in me was what i
needed to
get over my fear and apply applied mit
and that that is how i
got in um i came here as an undergrad
and i came to the
admittance day weekend and it was a lot
different than all of the other colleges
i had been to
and everyone i met was really
interesting so i sort of just decided to
come
and then once i was here it became
really hard to leave so i'm still here